trois émigrés soviétique aux mains
depuis le début de l'après midi d'un
commando arabe qui s'est emparé d'un
train à la frontière entre l'autriche et
la tchécoslovaque la législation sur les
faillites avec lui le président pompidou
l'a bien dit hier le gouvernement décidé
à accroître les garanties pour les
salariés
signature sans doute la prochaine du
contrat pétrochimique entre la france et
la chine le plus important jamais conclu
il porte sur une somme de 1 milliard 200
millions de francs entre vers des
consultations politiques entre la france
et le japon c'est ce qu'a proposé
monsieur pompidou à monsieur tanaka le
premier ministre japonais reçu
aujourd'hui à l'elysée où en sont les
derniers progrès en matière de médecine
et de chirurgie le point au 27e
entretiens de bichat qui ont débuté cet
après midi et jusqu'au 16 octobre dire
mais le meurtrier d'un motard de la
police a sauvé sa tête devant la cour
d'assises de paris
il a été condamné à la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité
fernand raynaud est mort dans un
accident de la route cet après midi
l'accident s'est produit près de riom
dans le massif central
fernand raynaud qui conduisait sa rolls
royce est entré en collision avec un
camion qui venait en sens inverse
melamed mazel messieurs bonsoir la
nouvelle de la mort de fernand raynaud a
été connue brutalement il y a à peine
une demi-heure le monde des variétés en
france perd avec fernand raynaud l'une
des vedettes les plus populaires de
notre pays
fernand raynaud était âgé de 47 ans il
était né à clermont-ferrand dans le
puy-de-dôme
c'est dans le puy de dôme qu'il est mort
près dorion fernand raynaud était marié
laisse deux enfants il avait fait ses
tout premiers débuts dans un cabaret à
pigalle en 1946 mais il s'était surtout
fait connaître à la radio dans les
émissions de jean nohain fernand raynaud
a été l'auteur de nombreux sketches
célèbre vous les connaissez et
l'interprète de nombreux films son
ambition et on peut dire à cet égard que
sa carrière a été une réussite
c'était de faire rire fernand raynaud
avait obtenu en 1970 de triomphe de la
popularité au music hall
je vous propose d'écouter l'extrait d'un
de ses sketchs les plus célèbres on a
bien public - charles admiration pour
ceux qui font des émissions de variétés
à la télé sans public sort du chapeau ça
marche je crois que dans les émissions
de variétés à la télé a beaucoup
il règle le disque sous le bras alors il
se casse pas la tête
ils ont pas le trac ils ont très bon
caractère
tout va bien il a gamera qui est
appréciable deuxième champion d'après
notre chanteuse moi je pense que les
variétés c'est un contact et le
téléspectateur c'est un peu comme s'ils
étaient dans la salle
alors si nous y voyons pas passé le même
de manière à l'eau alors asnières oui
oui je viens de recevoir à l'instant la
première réaction de bruno coquatrix le
directeur de l'olympia
j'avais beaucoup d'amitié pour fernand
raynaud a dit bruno coquatrix
je l'avais vu débuter dans les années 50
54 55 à l'olympia j'estime qu'il était
l'un des plus grands talents de notre
corporation et qu'il n'est hélas pas
aller au bout de son talent voilà ce que
vient de déclarer à l'instant monsieur
bruno coquatrix
demain la deuxième partie de notre
édition de 13h sera essentiellement
consacrée à un hommage rendu à fernand
raynaud encore une prise d'otages
encore une question comment va-t-elle se
terminer cela s'est passé tout au début
de l'après midi
deux arabes étaient montés dans un train
assurant la liaison bratislava viennent
à la frontière autrichienne
il s'emparait de trois migrants
soviétique et d'un douanier autrichien
les trois migrants faisait partie d'un
groupe de 37,8 soviétique
aussitôt les deux arabes réclamaient un
avion pour gagner le proche orient
il obtenait dans un premier temps une
camionnette avec laquelle ils se
dirigèrent vers l'aéroport de vienne
il se déclarèrent alors prêt à relâcher
le douanier autrichien si on les
laissait partir avec les trois otages
on apprenait ensuite dans l'après midi
que les deux arabes étaient porteurs des
passeports libanais ensuite les
autorités autrichiennes se déclarait
prête à fournir un avion aux ravisseurs
à condition que ceux ci libère tous les
otages alors qu'il est la situation est
celle que je viens de vous décrire les
deux arabes menace de faire sauter la
camionnette
dans laquelle ils se trouvent à
l'aéroport de vienne si on ne leur donne
pas l'avion qu'ils réclament
voyons les images qui ne sont pas
revenues cet après-midi un appareil
affrété par les autorités autrichiennes
est venu se ranger à côté de l'avion de
la compagnie iberia
celui ci devait emmener les otages et
les deux commandos palestiniens mais le
groupe est toujours dans une camionnette
la camionnette qui l'a conduit à
l'aéroport c'est à la gare frontière de
marché entre l'autriche et la
tchécoslovaquie que les deux terroristes
qui se réclament des aides de palestine
aux attaques théâtre un train à bord
duquel se trouvaient des migrants juifs
soviétiques après une courte fusillade
les palestiniens vont s'emparer de
quatre otages trois migrants téa
douaniers autrichien vous le voyez
d'ailleurs sur ces images menacé par
l'un des palestiniens
le commando utilisera ce douanier comme
intermédiaire il va réussir à s'emparer
d'une camionnette et y faire monter les
prisonniers
la camionnette partira aussitôt vers
l'aéroport de chouettes chape dans la
banlieue ouest de vienne
on pense généralement que c'est à
bratislava en tchécoslovaquie que les
terroristes sont montés à bord du train
c'est cette ligne bratislava vienne
complet le plus souvent les migrants
juifs lorsqu'il quitte l'union
soviétique à destination d'israël
il y avait trente sept migrants dans le
train attaqué aujourd'hui pour eux la
gare de marchais que c'est un peu la
porte de la liberté
il est probable que les otages
prisonniers sur l'aéroport de vienne
comptait déjà les heures qui les
séparaient la terre promise
le chancelier autrichien bruno kreisky a
convoqué les ambassadeurs d'irak de
libye d'egypte et du liban d'autre part
on annonce que la situation à l'aéroport
ne devrait pas évoluer avant 21h heure
de paris à tel aviv
les fêtes du nouvel an juif ont été
interrompues
deux entretiens et un déjeuner avec le
président pompidou une conférence de
presse la deuxième journée de la visite
de monsieur tanaka paris a été bien
remplie le premier tête à tête avec le
président de la république a commencé à
10h30 ce matin il a porté aussi bien sur
les questions internationales que sur
les relations franco-japonaises
l'entretien s'est poursuivie pendant le
déjeuner de 30 couverts offert en
l'honneur de monsieur tanaka au cours
d'une allocution le président pompidou a
mis l'accent sur la nécessité
d'approfondir les consultations entre
les deux pays la nécessité aussi de se
concerter sur les questions d'intérêt
commun telles que les négociations
commerciales et monétaires en coups sur
le développement des échanges
commerciaux
le président pompidou a précisé qu'ils
devront se faire dans un esprit de
libéralise et dekhili quant à monsieur
tanaka il s'est déclaré convaincu une
immense perspectives de coopération
mutuelle allait s'ouvrir dans de
nombreux domaines mais entretien avec le
président pompidou ont été très
fructueux at il déclaré à sa sortie de
l'elysée avant de retrouver le chef de
l'état pour un 2ème tête à tête monsieur
tanaka donner une conférence de presse
sur les échanges commerciaux il affirmé
que son pays offrait de grandes
possibilités aux produits français
le japon serait prête aussi acheter de
l'uranium enrichi produit par l'europe
sur le concorde
le prix de l'appareil ne devrait pas
poser de problème si le japon décidé de
l'acheter échanges culturels enfin la
joconde sera exposé l'an prochain au
japon a également annoncé monsieur
tanaka
à bagdad couvre feu imposé depuis 3h du
matin l'aéroport est fermé au trafic
aérien et l'armée quadrillent la
capitale les autorités irakiennes
affirme que ces mesures permettent de
rechercher les coupables des derniers
assassinats
il y aurait eu hier une tentative de
complot peut être dirigée par les
partisans de l'ancien chef de la sûreté
exécuté en juillet dernier
chibi après l'arrestation de monsieur
luis khalfallah ne me voie du parti
communiste chilien d'exode poursuite
comme la suède la suisse ou l'inde le
mexique reçoit les réfugiés voici le
premier convoi du point aérien arrivant
à mexico la france a fait savoir qu'elle
était prête à assumer sa part dans
l'accueil des réfugiés
bref compte-rendu en union soviétique
via l'agencé tass qui se félicite de la
fidélité de la france à la politique de
détente et de coopération avec les
européens
tu as ne manque pas de souligner que le
président n'a donné qu'un bref aperçu de
sa visite en chine populaire
satisfaction en allemagne de l'ouest où
l'on considère que georges pompidou en
fait rendu un hommage aussi inhabituel
qu'amicale à willy brandt
on est heureux de voir confirmer qu'il
n'y a pas de désaccord entre paris et
bonn
cette conférence de presse est jugée à
londres moins dramatique que celle du
général de gaulle une chose sans égal
la politique française n'a pas changé
vis-à-vis de l'amérique on regrette par
ailleurs que le neuf ne fasse pas un
front commun dans le mix entre harnes
l'opinion est la même à bruxelles où
l'on regrette que cette conférence de
presse n'est pas apporté de révélations
tout juste dit on des confirmations
on est malgré tout satisfait par les
perspectives nouvelles de l'europe et de
la fin de la sphère chirac
la presse italienne retient l'europe
dans les différents thèmes abordés elle
regrette le pessimisme présidentielle
sur l'union politique européenne et
s'inquiète de voir renaître en france
une peur de l'allemagne tout entre paris
et bonn n'a pas l'air d'aller si bien
lit-on en italie déception à la haye en
apprenant que paris fera d'autres
expériences atomiques
mais ici comme ailleurs officiellement
aucune réaction
officieusement à alger par le canal de
algérie presse service
force est de constater que les solutions
avancées par le président pompidou sont
limitées à la canalisation de
l'immigration et non à la mise en place
de mesures énergiques contre le racisme
je vais vous éviter tout de suite de
calculer ce que représentent les 8 0 que
vous venez de voir cela fait 1 milliard
200 millions c'est-à-dire 120 milliards
d'anciens francs
c'est ce qui représente ce fameux
contrat entre la france et la chine le
plus important jamais conclu entre les
deux pays
le président pompidou il ya fait
allusion hier dans sa conférence de
presse en réponse à un journaliste qui
lui demandait de faire le bilan de sa
récente visite officielle en chine
non seulement c'est le plus gros contrat
franco chinois mais il est de taille
puisqu'il s'agit de fournir à la chine
une vingtaine d'unités pétrochimique
le complexe serait construit dans la
région de pékin
une fois signée la première conséquence
de la signature de ce contrat entre la
france et la chine sera une nouvelle
manière de regarder la carte mondiale du
commerce
ce sera en effet l'ouverture du premier
marché potentiel du monde
le contrat prévoit la construction d'un
complexe pétrochimique dans la région de
pékin
une vingtaine d' usine le composeront
elles produiront principalement des
fibres synthétiques comme le polyester
et le nylon la chine constitue
indiscutablement nouveaux flux
d'exportations pour la france je dis
bien flux et non pas
pas allusion à une série momentanée de
vente est bien plutôt un mouvement
continu d'exportation qui s'étendra dans
le temps et qui concernera non seulement
la chine mais aussi des pays limitrophes
deuxième conséquence du contrat un coût
deux fois sur les relations commerciales
franco chinoises ces relations sont
restées instable jusqu'à maintenant
la france est encore que le cinquième
partenaire commercial de la chine et des
échanges ne dépasse pas 1% des
exportations françaises
les industriels font de cependant
beaucoup d'espoir dans les négociations
futures
certes depuis l'an dernier les relations
sont déficitaires pour la france mais
nombreux sont les signes prometteurs
les contacts se multiplient le président
confie d'où vient de se rendre en chine
enfin ce contrat de plus d'un milliard
de francs le plus important connu dans
le monde industriel la législation en
matière de faillites est dépassé la
sphère lit pas poser le problème
le patronat a admis qu'une évolution
était nécessaire et hier au cours de sa
conférence de presse le chef de l'état a
indiqué que les modifications devaient
intervenir
le but améliorer la situation les
travailleurs victimes de la déconfiture
d'une entreprise lorsque les jugements
de faillite puis le liquidation des
biens sont actuellement rendu par le
tribunal de commerce un syndic et nommer
son rôle redistribués aux différents
intéressés
l'actif de la société c'est-à-dire la
valeur totale de lusine des machines des
stocks et des réserves financières
l'ordre des priorités des créanciers et
bien sûr l'aspect déterminant de cette
législation
en premier lieu les salariés de
l'entreprise touche un salaire pour
leurs 60 derniers jours de travail avec
une limite cependant cette somme ne peut
excéder 1466 francs par mois soit 2932
francs pour
moi l'existence de ce plafond limite
sensiblement les garanties offertes aux
salariés
le syndic doit alors payer les frais de
justice
puis il rembourse au trésor public les
sommes dues par l'entreprise impôts
impayés par exemple vient ensuite au
quatrième rang des priorités la sécurité
sociale aqis le syndic doit payer les
dettes de la société depuis un ou deux
ans selon les cas
c'est à ce niveau et à ce niveau
seulement que les salariés peuvent
bénéficier de remboursements
supplémentaires les salaires impayés par
l'entreprise depuis six mois les congés
payés honoré dans leur totalité et les
indemnités de licenciement plafonné
comme les deux derniers mois de salaires
pour les travailleurs à 1466 enfin s'il
reste encore de l'argent dans les
caisses
le syndic doit payer les dettes de
l'entreprise envers les banques et les
entreprises sous traitants c'est cet
ordre de priorité que le chef de l'état
s'est donc engagé hier à faire modifier
le gouvernement qui prépare actuellement
un nouveau texte aura pour objectif
numéro un
d'améliorer la situation des salariés en
les plaçant dans une position plus
favorable vis-à-vis des autres
créanciers
huit mille litres de lait déversés sur
la chaussée mais aussi 600 kg de gruyère
distribué hier soir à pontarlier les
agriculteurs des laitiers du doubs
entendait réclamer le relèvement du prix
du lait et protester contre la mévente
du gruyère quelques incidents sérieux
devant la sous préfecture avec les
forces de l'ordre le calme devrait
revenir tard dans la soirée
réduire le déséquilibre entre zones
urbaines et zones rurales principales
conclusions de la conférence européenne
des ministres de l'aménagement du
territoire qui s'est achevée à la grande
motte prochaine conférence dans deux ans
en italie
dans l'intervalle un comité
international de haut fonctionnaire
maintiendra la liaison entre ministres
le groupe eu des airs de l'assemblée
nationale devra se donner un nouveau
président la semaine prochaine roger
frey donne sa démission pour raisons de
santé
il entend se reposer au moins un an
je n'ai jamais voulu tuer un homme
je demande pardon c'est tout avec des
sanglots dans la voix guy hervé a
peut-être sauvé sa tête à cet instant
précis 1h40 plus tard le temps des
délibérations du jury des assises de
paris
le meurtrier de l'agent motocyclistes
andré biche et est donc condamné à la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité
hervé qui tout au long de l'après midi
avait attendu le verdict
la tête baissée le teint livide s'est
alors levé il a esquissé un sourire en
serrant les mains de son avocat
nul doute que la plaidoirie de maître
philippe lemaire a aidé les jurés à
répondre oui quand on leur a demandé
hervé at il des circonstances
atténuantes pour l'avocat général je
vous le disais hier soir le crime de
guerre v est celui d'un véritable
tuèrent réponse cet après-midi de mettre
le maire
si hervé avait eu l'intention de tirer
il n'aurait pas signé son acte en
donnant au brigadier son permis de
conduire des circonstances atténuantes m
le maire en a trouvé dans la famille du
condamné trois de ses aïeux se sont
suicidés sa mère alcoolique ne lui a
rendu qu'une seule visite à fresnes
pendant quatre années de détention
elle était tellement ivre ce jour là
raconte m le maire que hervé effondré a
préféré ne pas l'avoir réaction des
policiers en civil présents et toujours
silencieux à l'audience on a davantage
penser à l'assassin qu'à sa victime il
reste en effet que le brigadier bisch a
été abattu en service commandé il ya
quatre ans et demi et que sa veuve a
gardé au coeur un sentiment de révolte
nous le comprenons a certifié m le maire
mais faut-il répondre au meurtre par le
meurtre futile légal un procès s'achève
un débat continue entre les partisans et
les adversaires de la peine de mort
un fouga magister de la patrouille de
france s'est écrasé aujourd'hui vers
midi 1 2 km environ de salon de provence
c'est au cours de l'entraînement
biquotidien des pilotes de la patrouille
que l'accident s'est produit
le pilote le lieutenant alain gilbert
est mort carbonisé
il avait 31 ans et appartenaient à la
patrouille de france depuis 1970 il
totalisait 2500 heures de vol un nouveau
cas de choléra enregistrés en france
une fillette de sept mois et est
hospitalisé à paris après un séjour de
deux mois en algérie
la famille de la petite malade c'est
l'objet d'investigations minutieuses
mais l'organisation mondiale de la santé
confirme qu'aucune partie du territoire
français
l'êta considérée comme sont infectés
affaire markovic l'unique inculpé de la
sphère françois marcantoni a été entendu
à deux reprises aujourd'hui par le juge
d'instruction ferrer au cours de
l'audition il a été confronté avec
hureaux smilovic son principal
accusateur
ce dernier a semble-t-il confirmé qu'il
avait récemment rencontré marc anthony
ce qui accréditerait la thèse selon
laquelle me levitch proviendrait sur ces
accusations obsèques à la romaine pour
anna magnani devant l'église une foule
considérable était massée très tôt ce
matin pour rendre hommage à la grande
actrice italienne décédé à l'âge de 65
ans
l'argentin carlos monzon va mettre pour
la huitième fois samedi soir à roland
garros son titre mondial des moyens
l'homme de la pampa terminé sa
préparation à la salle filippi à ça je
trouve nettement mieux que la dernière
fois il a l'air ils adhèrent déjà au
poids est très affûté
si on peut dire ça en meilleure
condition va être en quoi vous dites il
paraît mieux en quoi paraît pas une
expression as soon as lu à sa façon sa
façon de le faire et d5 est un homme qui
arrive à la au maximum de ce qu'on peut
faire à poigne je fais plus loin il est
toujours avec toujours présent puis
versez rapide et coupes fluides
il vous impressionne vraiment
impressionné le début
pour boxer assez rigide in both aussi
développé que lorsqu'il est à côté du
chauffeur contre griffiths il était
resté longtemps sans boxer il a eu des
problèmes dès maintenant il est en
meilleure forme que jamais
jean claude bouttier lui est à la salle
des sports de saint mandé sera-t-il 11e
français champion du monde
c'est un garçon qui est très athlétique
surtout depuis ces derniers mois il a
travaillé la musculation est devenu très
très puissant alors que au départ
c'était un garçon plutôt malingue
par contre il a une chose au 15 mai mais
poids moyen avec celle punch saint-paul
shirts le vrai puncheur et avec un
puncheur
surtout lorsqu un puncheur est doublée
d'un garçon intelligent et qui réfléchit
à ce qui fait tous les espoirs sont
permis
stéphane vraiment et à préparer chaque
match toutes ces conditions idéales et
je pense que c'est le mot raki contrat
ge france si les étangs du jour du match
et que le public vienne nombreux pouvoir
gagner aussi qu'il applaudit debout coup
là je pense que laurent blanc avant mon
premier combat je pensais mongeon
presque inaccessible aujourd'hui non je
crois que tout est possible
je sais ce qu'il faudrait faire pour le
battre jouer moi savoir c'est à dire
qu'il faut que je fasse pression sur lui
que j'anticipe sur ces attaques que
j'aille plus vite qu'elle vit qu'en fait
beaucoup de choses comme ça maintenant
c'est ce que j'ai travaillé maintenant
il faudra le mettre en pratique c'est
autre chose parce que l'us laissera pas
faire j'en suis persuadé ce serait bucci
chances pour qu'il a su nous y croyons
tous beaucoup vainqueur disons ça
m'était difficile de donner le vainqueur
ce que je fais c'est que j'ai vu quand
même jean claude bouttier pour bien le
décontracté qu'il soit en bonne forme
comme j'ai fait le cagnard le tour de
force mais je femme risque est
aujourd'hui à faire un pronostic je veux
lui amener la chance si la télévision
n'existait pas il n'y aurait que hier
soir que quelques centaines de
privilégiés à pouvoir assister à paris
au théâtre des champs elysées à ce que
les américains appellent le diana ross
show son et été bien dommage car les
véritables admirateurs de cette grande
chanteuse américaine n'était pas
nécessairement ceux invités à la soirée
de gala au même moment sortait sur les
grands écrans parisiens le célèbre film
lady sings the blues après la scène de
music hall et le cinéma
diana ross n'a pas l'intention d'en
rester là puisqu'elle veut maintenant
tout apprendre sur le show-business une
façon comme une autre
d'améliorer sa situation la voici dans
un extrait du film précisément lady
sings the blues violence
billie holiday lady day pour ses
admirateurs la plus grande chanteuse de
blues morte à 44 ans trop de drogues
elle inspiré un film l'aider sings the
blues présenté hier à paris
il est joué par diana ross 15 fois best
seller du disque
k
ap
vie fut celle d'une enfant sans père né
dans la misère bonne à tout faire dans
une maison mal famé de baltimore puis
pensionnaires à part entière dans cette
mission
le nommant
son talent lui permet d'en sortir elle
chante dans une boîte de nuit minable où
les clients donnent des pourboires aux
attractions
lle découverte et part en tournée
première noire à chanter avec un
orchestre blanc et rencontres dans les
états du sud les persécutions raciales
pire que celle de new york surtout les
limes charge érotique au club scan est
bien le seul à qui on a refusé le droit
de chanter dans les boîtes de nuit et
les groupes fini sur la scène de
carnegie hall qui est quelque chose
entre fly et les l'opéra elle chanteuse
de blues né dans les faubourgs
1' son autobiographie dans la traduction
vient de paraître en france elle a
raconté sa carrière pleine d'accrocs les
deux fois arrêté pour usage de drogue
augustin
c'est lui
que sa fille
elle subit en prison les affres de
désintoxication brutale
elle voit mourir sous ses yeux son
pianiste battu à mort elle avait pour
ami les vrais un joueur un peu cox terre
comme entre dans le film sous les dehors
les plus aimables soucieux de la santé
physique et mentale des milices
et c'est là que le film pêche bien
avancé trop chaud ni trop soigné la
drogue semble être pour elle une variété
de bonbons à la menthe en un peu plus
toxiques
celle qui en usent n'en perd pas un
souci
même pas un kilo ian napa le regard
dévastée de billy mais elle est très
élevée on en a jugé hier à paris ou en
chair en os et la donne est un gars là
son grand succès le blues america le
français mon homme ma nayla en souvenir
de bijoux les des der
pour ceux d'entre vous qui n'étaient pas
avec nous au début de cette édition je
vous rappelle une nouvelle qui touche
naturellement tous les français fernand
raynaud est mort cet après-midi dans un
accident de voiture
je vous rappelle aussi que demain la
deuxième partie de notre édition de 13
heures sera consacrée à un hommage rendu
à fernand raynaud l'actualité continue
d'une dernière dépêche vient d'arriver
et me dit que les agents de conduite de
paris-saint-lazare feront une grève de
24 heures et cela dimanche prochain donc
après demain mesdames et messieurs bonne
soirée